yes dr. Wallach
I suffer from COPD I was wondering if
you could help me with that okay how are
you sir
I'm 68 years old sir
okay and how tall are you I'm six - okay
and how much you weigh approximately
right around 213 okay now do you have
any history as a kid of asthma or
bronchitis yes I've had one kindness
before that's an adult years ago
okay and then did you ever have any skin
problems and the eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis or rosacea no sir okay about
any constipation diarrhea appendicitis
irritable bowel syndrome of that real
also on oh nothing consistent but just
off and on okay all right there's
actually a hormone that's required to
keep the bronchi the main Airways or the
branch off from your trachea one brought
one bronchi goes to the left lung one
bronchi go to the right lung and don't
get small the inner inner space inside
those bronchi I'll get a smaller
diameter than a ballpoint pen if you
don't have that hormone your lungs like
to make that hormonal right but it could
taste raw materials to do it and so very
very often times people with COPD or
really severe asthma these sorts of
things will be caused by deficiency of
that hormone now let's see here Shar yes
we're talking about a whole combination
of respiratory stuff right okay and one
of the reasons why a person might not
get the raw materials to make that
hormone to keep those bronchi dilated
which should be about as big around as a
nickel or a quarter as opposed to
diamond ballpoint pen okay what's
happening why could you not absorb that
nutrient I'm well I would imagine us
because they've not
absorbing it because they've got a
gluten intolerance um they can't okay
and Donald has another little symptom
he's got diarrhea every once awhile
which is yeah which can go along with
gluten problems and he has a history of
bronchitis as a younger person and so I
mean I get people calling me at one of
them are in their doctor says they only
have hours to live
and we give them the 90 essential
nutrients plus that raw material and
these respiratory issues get better and
so they get taken out of these sort of
emergency room crisis situation okay but
you have to do this constantly and so
what you give this guy would you give
Donald in addition to a gluten-free diet
what what program would you give him to
deal with respiratory problems in
general and also to give his lung as the
raw materials they need to make that
hormone to keep the airways dilated I
give him two healthy brain and heart
packs okay per general yes well actually
he's going to get a lot of that raw
material in there and he need to take
six of those capsules of breakfast and
six of those capsules dinner time and
he'll be able to do that was they too
healthy printed hard packed okay and
that'll gave him the 90s sense of
nutrients and so that we go there he's
gonna be gluten free and then what other
thing would you add well one thing you
could add would be the oxy body very
good get some oxygen going here oxy
Bonnie said liquid I'd go ahead and a
guy your size Donal you could take two
quarts a month so the oxy Bonnie tastes
very good is kind of a cherry berry
flavor and it's an oxygen supplement is
the liquid oxygen supplement you can
take an ounce hour before breakfast an
ounce an hour before dinnertime and that
will help increase the oxygen levels in
the blood okay it's an oxygen supplement
and what else what would you do to help
the body's stem cells make things I give
them the eMeter tell them very good very
good okay get yourself two bottles of
the MRT Liam and that will again kind of
support your stem cells activity the
ones you have and encourage your tissues
including your lung tissues your
bronchitis or
to make more stem cells so they can do
their jobs and then call us and two
weeks in four weeks in six weeks and let
us know how the COPD is anytime you go
to the doctor you get some kind of
assessment let us know what's going on
there and we'll walk you through this
very common stuff okay but it is
something you can deal with